how's tomorrow
um London was cool
you know it's uh makes you appreciate
the sun back home
it's been shitty there
I mean it's just their typical weather
you know it's just kind of gray it's not
it's not bad but it's just you know it's
different
um
what would you say no I was gonna say
when the sun comes out you're like oh
thank God you know you really yeah but
anyway you're gonna say I asked you this
via text but like you do have like
American history stuff in your set do
people get it there
um they know yeah yeah so
yeah I think like there's definitely a a
tongue-in-cheek way that I like kind of
Bring It Up
um I think the the toughest one was like
some of the Scandinavian shows like
Finland
um or or uh like Helsinki Oslo and and
Sweden I actually had a guy message me
after one of the shows he was like yo
man great show but I don't really get
one of the bits
and so I actually like I took the time
and I explained it to him
that's a hilarious thing to message a
comedian after yeah yeah was hey can you
help me understand this part of your
show yeah
yeah and I was it was it felt genuine so
I just you know I I bit and um send them
away just like killing America yeah
yeah it just took the time to it like
explain it and he then like he got he's
like oh he's like [__] man me and my
girlfriend felt so stupid because
everyone was like laughing around us and
we were just kind of lost and I said no
the the bit is massively American so
like you know it's kind of asking a lot
from you like all the way in [__]
Sweden to
piece some of it together
um
I you know like I know like he got it
but I think when I gave him the full
context it was like it clicked and he's
like oh okay right all right I'll tell
you the most nervous I was was [__]
Ireland why
Irish [__] are funny dude oh
really yeah they're all funny every
every person I encountered in in Dublin
just had like a witty
you know it starts it starts here I
didn't talk about this right
no no okay so I get to my hotel in
Dublin
and uh our Bellman you older gentleman
you know nice guy like kind of like uh
just big old Smiles so we come
downstairs and we're about to go out for
dinner
and I said uh I said hey man
um what's Irish humor like he's like
Irish humor
I'll tell you about Irish humor and then
he does like a joke like just back
pocket does a bit I'm like oh man that's
funny I'm like
all right cool what was the jump like
I don't remember but here's why okay so
then I say
I'm like all right it seems like maybe
it's like there's a dark appetite uh I'm
like do people care if you joke about
the church and [__] because you know
I've I've heard about you know different
things about whatever
and he's like oh sure
you can he's like you could joke about
the church then he does like I'm not
exaggerating there's three jokes about
like God and Jesus and someone else like
just offhand I'm like okay you think
it's his own [__] no no like there are
definitely little like you know he was
like I got a tight five actually about
the church yeah well dude that's how it
felt I feel like I could well so here's
the thing so that was like my first
taste right
so then we go out for dinner whatever
the next day
um I'm still like a little bit nervous
because I'm like man you know it just
feels like everyone here kind of has
like a confidence about them uh
to like just you know they just they're
confident people so then we go eat
breakfast and I sit down and the table's
kind of off-kilter so I put my hands
down on the table and it like wobbles
and then there's like two bottles of
like sauce and they fall over
and then the guy working there without
skipping a [__] beat he's like geez
take out the door as well with you're
like something like like I think he said
geez why don't you take the door out
with you as well like
you know and it was just like it was so
unexpected and super funny and the way
it like came across is like he was like
he knew me as a person yeah yeah and so
I laughed and then
and then that in the venue I was like
meeting the venue staff
and uh the sound guys are you know they
kind of like they're just kind of funny
and then even one of the guys like one
of the promoters
um I walk in the room and he goes to
shake my hand and I was I was like
eating so I like closed my fist and I
was like I was like my hands are
disgusting man like let me do that and
he goes ah yeah I that's what I thought
when I saw you I said that is a man with
disgusting hands
so then it's just all kind of getting in
my head like [__] like [__] everyone
here is a comedian yeah yeah and then uh
one of the sound guys told me that it's
like a it's a bit they're kind of like a
stereotype about Irish people where
um they'll go watch a show and they'll
be like ah the [__] show sucked but
we were good
you know he's like we all think we're
funny and we all think like we're better
than the person performing so
um I like went in there and I was just
like okay I gotta [__] hunker down
and I'm like fully prepared for like a
drunk ass crowd
you know the longer the show goes the
funnier than me they're gonna think they
are and uh it didn't you know it ended
up being like a really great show you
know uh because like I think definitely
like one of the best just because like
just crazy energy and stuff but
um they Hackle you
uh they did like in a positive way like
at points they're like definitely like
being part of the show and like having
fun with it so I you know it was it was
good
um and then uh I like I felt like all my
fears were were valid because someone
messaged me after the show and they said
I fair play to you coming all the way to
Ireland and getting Dubliners to laugh I
was like oh [__] okay
yeah so yeah the whole thing was uh but
I didn't understand that one part of
yours dude dude I didn't even [__]
around with like mocking them like that
yeah I was like
I'm like you know it when it's like us
two up there it's fine because like we
can be like you know back to the wall
the two of us
you know yeah yeah pointing like the
humor pistols at the room and like it
can be like a fun thing when I'm
standing out there on my own I'm like
hey let me chill out
[Laughter]
and then we have to make our way to
um
uh where the [__] are we going
we're going to Birmingham no burning man
yeah Burning Man no we're going to
Sheffield
on the way to Sheffield and on the way
I get a little message from the from the
casino God himself so you know Siva he
sends me a text he goes hey man you
should stop over at uh
Warhammer World in Nottingham no way I'm
like the [__] is Warhammer world
you know and he's like
oh man it's this like
mega store this and that they got
exhibitions there and I'm thinking
so we map it out
and sure enough Warhammer world is just
but a slight detour
so I popping we pop into Warhammer World
shout out to this guy Kieran really nice
guy
recognize we walk in and he's like hey
man you want to check out the
exhibitions I'm like yeah sure
so we go through five rooms of like
massively
um just cool
Warhammer [__] you know they got the
first Space Marine up in a cabinet you
know they got some of the original
figurines from like the 80s and you know
I know people
in the sort of like Games Workshop World
got mixed feelings about Warhammer and
the cost and whatever but if you put all
that [__] aside man
some of the most elaborate just dope
exhibitions there you're talking like
scenes that are constructed that are
like three layers deep from every
direction you look around the glass you
know yeah they got like
[__] minimum like
300 pieces per thing you know they had
they had one table at the end that was
probably like 10 by 15 feet and a
staircase wrapped around it it's that
one right there it's that same room
um
but I believe the one I was looking at
was different
and the official
yeah yeah yeah Place yeah yeah it's like
the Games Workshop
uh it's not in Sheffield they said
nodding him why they're
um maybe
it originated there maybe that's like
their HQ yo click the one with the
purple I think that might be a recent
picture
um
oh my God this is this isn't even
this is not even the Finish though this
I think is
what I saw
I don't know maybe it's just a picture
but like what I saw had much more detail
in terms of the paint and stuff
um I took a bunch of videos I can't even
send them here but
uh you know I had one like little
sketchy moment where I pulled out my
phone and I put it like landscape and I
started like filming in cinematic mode
and like panning like over the yeah that
purple image right there I started
panning over the characters and [__]
and I had this intrusive thought
afterward like damn what if I just
dropped the phone and I just hit like 15
figures
you know I just I shook that feeling off
so quickly
um
I just pull up just like a dumbass dude
just like um
imagine if we got invited to some like
installation and we dropped one of the
props imagine we could talk about we can
talk about that now dude
we've been Bank yes dude the money we're
that they're not getting that money back
all right so uh yeah when when Cody and
I went to San Diego to promote the new
Game of Thrones and we dropped one of
the [__] dragon eggs
we should play the video now we have a
[__] video dude we we need to ask if
we could do that funny
well I shouldn't say
uh no mazad we should just check in to
see how she feels about it
it's funny though because
okay yeah that after maybe yeah yeah the
bonus you're gonna give Cody flashbacks
hide that thing
but yeah I know what you're saying like
you
yeah so owner you trip into the exhibit
yeah
so you know this thing is genius because
then I come out of there yeah yeah bro
dude I was picturing just tripping and
just knocking over a hundred pieces with
my elbow like oops dumbass American yeah
sorry guys I was filming it and then
yeah so um can I write you a guys a
check for this and we're all elsewhere
about that guys I know you like the big
greens yes sorry you know what's the
what's the cost production on these
things like three cents per